oh you got it on video dude that's so
during my set dude they actually
underestimate me well yeah
he didn't hit the parkway he didn't get
the part where he gets tackled did you
get any part of him no there was no
crowd there was no tackle yes i got the
running do you think it was like a good
thing that he got policed or do you
think that it was a unjust
because his dog they're gonna impound
his dog and yeah they're probably gonna
kill him they're gonna pound his dog
they're not kidding though
they're gonna they the cops told us
they're to pound his dog
yeah this is beautiful i mean you
impound vehicles
yeah can i get my 2 000 record
shepard please
shane was recording it so we'll get up
oh my god we got it on video him running
holy [ __ ] oh yeah let me see it
there's the cop just there but he was
like stumbling he was like
the cop was getting drunk
was hammered
you should contact the police because
don't contact the police no dude [ __ ]
that police and say you're all drunk i
could get that dude [ __ ] out of jail
like that's a huge dude he might have
been a arrested guy well he stole 600
yeah he robbed someone with 600 bucks
out that's not that much money i know
probably so many that's a weak attack
no yeah does he deserve to go to jail
for [ __ ] years for that his dog's
here i don't think this is not like a
happy dog i think he should go to jail
five days to learn his lesson and then
give him a dollar and give his [ __ ]
dog
all right don't yeah don't get any of
that stand up it was pretty rancid but
however if i was the guy that got that
six hundred dollars stolen i'm not the
police chief
the bartender was beat the [ __ ] out of
him yeah the bar didn't even do shoes
like he stole 600. we got to keep this
dog as evidence
no really we took we took the dog for a
walk and then he chased us out and tried
to take the leash because he was like we
need that dog on the property and we
were like
the guy was like damn i'm going to call
three 11. now this guy is a real scum he
said this like four times he's like this
guy's already said that no the the the
bartender
he's the bartender that's worse he came
over and he's like i'm gonna say this
one time yeah he's like we called it's
elected yeah
situation here and none of us knew what
that meant yeah i know he's like
what if he was like at one point when he
was saying that he was like i've been
working here 16 straight hours today
i'm like
dude uh well that guy that one
particular guy is such a heart oh yeah
he always complains but like he keeps
coming back like i feel like he i feel
like he likes it
yeah i know he's just like he's always
complaining he's coming back because
he's getting hate
i'm telling you
[Music]
police officer was legitimately drunk
like you don't yeah yeah you don't get
it in the video i watched him stumble
like like a drunk person when he talked
legit though like he's got that guy out
of his whole system
no seriously if the cop is and he could
probably get a bunch of money too yeah
maybe you're drunk chased him around
dude don't you find a lawyer
show him the video you're doing what so
right everyone was really white about
this so ray was doing a set he had a
class kick
so ray was doing a set and then the
police chased the guy and tackled him
right during this they didn't tackle the
guy got away yeah the guy the guy
got out of there
they never found it
i forgot riley had a phone
no no
because i saw him i saw him push him
against the wall and then i just turned
around like oh they got him no no no
he hopped out and ran you know
that's how it works
that's how it works in the mind of a
white man
like yeah he's got him
well i got on the video the the the the
hard-ass bartender like
you shows him like try to punch him or
something
like her like pushing or something like
you know putting zero effort he's trying
to get it with the girl who got her 600
dollars stolen how does she get 600
dollars apparently this guy who had the
dog stole her six hundred dollars and
then the bartender was like she needed
to pay her rent don't you understand
that that's why you kept trying
how did
six
six yeah i mean six hundred dollars is a
lot yeah that's not that much
are we trying to find out who goes first
six
so how much is a felony
twenty dollars five what you're kidding
that's
so i go first and it goes left and then
it does a
snake so i go first then you go twice
and it goes back all the way around
wonderful so we place two settlements on
a road and you want to pick a spot you
want to pick a vertex that has a lot of
dots on it
like this one has a lot of dots 5 plus 4
plus 3
that's 12.
this one has a lot of dots 5 plus 4 plus
4 that's 13.
so this would be a very valuable spot
this one's good too
let me go with this one
whoa gamer cam
look at that placement oh
does that make sense
are we live right now
yeah
okay are we alive exciting there's 11
000 people watching this right now no
way in my life
you're [ __ ] kidding me go to the
comments
i don't know how to do it you know how
to do it ray go on youtube wait so what
do you want to try and do chat uh uh
i don't i think you need to have twitch
open for that or whatever you're
streaming on it's like one of these
things
uh then you'd probably go to uh view
try view and then
huh
yeah look somewhere stream information
there's stream information there's a oh
there you go you got
no one is there no there's five people
watching no there's more on youtube i
don't know if it's combined or
wow restraining youtube
yeah because youtube there is at least
one
11 million likes
ask them if they're hungry
oh there we go
i love the diversity i'm not even on the
video on youtube
anyway
press live
oh wow yeah that's what you do
amazing
hello fellow gamers and streamers
we come in peace
i hope you allow us to
she's slightly male from yeah
i don't even know so it's your turn
right so you gotta pick a spot with a
lot of dots all right do i take any one
of these you put a little house
okay it can be any color okay yeah
okay
okay i got it
yeah so
all right so you said this was a good
spot over here
take my good spot
this is a good spot
this is real prime
over here
let's go right there
cool let's do that
look at you
can you get a close-up on gareth
for the shot
this makes a
three
one two three
that's four so seven
seven plus five so okay yeah
so this is 12.
okay we're just looking for that star
there
tony called you a half a guy on the cast
when you're on i thought it was a quick
reference what are you [ __ ] talking
about
hi man these are one viewer be kind i i
love you
you did an amazing stand-up by the way
not digging on you i listen i love you
and can you tell me how to play this
game by calling you a half a man or
something i i don't even know what that
means is it because i'm a slav i don't
know
well i'm not you [ __ ] i'm just kidding
have you guys ever been friends with a
[ __ ]
no no i have really it's really cool
i've only ever seen it on tv
it's not a contest i'm just saying
i'm a good person
i made friends with a guy that no one
could be friends with a friend yourself
oh no
hey
hey
but uh yeah we used to play street
hockey
and and he was the puck
mark can you get like more around the
corner yeah sure street
yeah oh i'm not gonna try teddy grahams
just scoot that little pedestal over
that's in the way yeah oh there you go
do you have any more beers
yeah gareth can riley have one of your
horse
thanks man
does anybody lost one beer oh yeah i'll
take one
yeah i'm not driving for the next hour
their beers
getting
yes thank you thanks for sharing sorry
sharing
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this you're watching the
you're watching uh some dirty [ __ ]
right now
uh it is your turn riley i've moved
by the way
sorry
i'm after hans and that's all that
matters to me right now
i'm also back in the
[Applause]
thank you thank you sir
damn bro who the [ __ ] is blue
we got a great spot look at him yeah i
was looking at it from the beginning
that's great wait so what is this piece
oh that's a bandit
oh boy
i don't know
bandit i call him the terrorist
this is going to turn into a circle jerk
it says i'm brad
aka
a
u-shaped jerk
i'm not drinking anyone off
just like y'all know
he's a mouth
hey
morgan green what's up man
what's up man
a long time no
chill
i don't know i just like uh
really mad because you guys took all the
good spaces
how do you just pretend that you're
playing as me so that and tell me what
to do right there's still multiple good
spaces yeah you're tripping dude i mean
it's a shame white took that though
because that would have been really good
yeah well i went first oh it was white
it's like if i had a swatch okay
i guess man i think that it's
appropriate that white got the first one
don't ask didn't even twice right got
the third move he just changed
so shane you get to go two in a row
just think about but i think you can't
be uh just one segment away from anyone
else could i be here
yeah hans would you be interested in any
thumbnails or promotional designs yes
thank you
i'll send you two dollars
is it han's turn no it's yeah it sneaks
this way it's riley's trick yeah i'm
[ __ ] here so pick up the resources
from your second settlement
okay
did i get all three yes
correct
the
so when i was home like my brother
thought there was a ghost to my house so
like the whole time i was home i was
just scared of the ghost
the ghost was your abusive father
well i mean and we're looking into
psychological age
the ghost is your pale family
yeah
god damn it
i don't know what i'm doing
uh but
yeah so um
but in the end i don't think i don't
know if there's a ghost
but like my uh so my brother said he was
like
uh like i felt something on my feet like
it's something to touch my feet dude i
completely it's called the wind that's
called schizophrenia dude
and then he's like he's like
he's like and then it pokes me through
the blanket
oh one of the poking feet fluttering
ghosts
but he was like he's like don't worry
it's a peaceful spirit
i was like i don't know like i don't
want something touching me
and poking me
yeah like if there's a guy in my house i
wouldn't be like oh
it's a peaceful spirit can you actually
give me like half of this right here oh
i'm sorry never mind thank you
this is our side
then what else
is this a table of taxes made
their big text is tough
rachel the girl that made it so that she
made it in some class
wow it's really hard to play katana
because it's not completely level
she [ __ ] it up
she didn't
in texas no you got to put this down
on a valuable location let's just play
squid games
all right
i'm going to go
would this be a good
mix
never watch what i want this to be yeah
you want to connect them if you can
because you get a bonus if you can
connect i've never watched squid games
okay at all i have no idea what else
haven't you watched
you take the resources uh touching your
second settlement
hey guys we should find a turtle and uh
give us some money
which is cheap yeah uh do you know
turtles love cocaine because they have
why is it there
yeah oh i thought they were i thought
they had numbers on them i thought
there's like you could like whip up your
bracelet
cocaine
my cleric is the heel spell it's all on
camera again i've done it yeah no you
can't do it
who is the lady with the glasses she's
hot
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah marcia these are our two females
yeah
that's what they said
that's from uh
playing too much smash brothers my bad
there's a guard there's marth
it's a solid character in smash brothers
that is a solid character it is solid
snake character whoa whoa this game
sucks dude i'm already losing who the
[ __ ] is going yeah i have my turn relax
i have the worst
spot possible you should try the desert
i hear that it's prime real estate yeah
that's good once these floods start
people are going to love the different
that's where bonnaroo is this year
um
food desert
tennessee so what are these the chance
card
pretty you like open it and it says go
to jail
he's an aptly man getting pulled away i
don't remember what buys what so i'm
waiting to just like kind of feel it out
based on what other people are doing
i'll give you the card
isn't there something that shows there's
like a little
little cheetah
the purple shirt guy looks like he wants
to smash somebody oh thank you oh wait
i'll take the balloon
wow
oh cool thank you definitely
it's always a nice little cheat sheet
okay i need brick
settlements i need
i need brick i need rock
five
nine might as well go here
[Laughter]
tim said can you buy black people in
this game
i was looking at that expansion i wasn't
looking at that part that's also great
but i saw i'd rather watch them stream
each other's pee into one another's
mouths hey who cares what they're
somebody else's talking about
[ __ ] that we're playing guitar you all
don't know how to read out loud
okay
seriously
read your mother's diary yeah
[ __ ] is this is this sex or nine
it's enough let's see where the dots are
yeah they're not they're gonna have
brick for this would you roll
six six
hell yeah
riley's on a times time lag
um anyone want
one wait wait does everybody take one of
your role six yeah everyone who has
said something oh [ __ ] oh i'm in the
money
anyone have
want brick
i do you want the uh half break
yeah the whole game is actually trading
and
all this [ __ ] happening on the board is
a lie the game is a trading game
he's lying
that was also a lie you've been
bamboozled six
yeah if you have anything on the six
then you get that resource whatever
numbers your resources oh yes they're
like settlements the rock hans rolled to
six too so you should you should have
already taken one i get the rock and the
stone and then another rock
what wait what
what
are you talking about
yeah because he's no he's got wood over
here oh no
oh okay you get a rock and you get a
stone oh you're going to win this stone
well yeah yeah yeah another one yeah
you get two wood you get two now i
notice you have no sheep you want to
trade me uh i have a sheep you [ __ ]
sucker
goddamn beige
you see that they give you a sheep for a
wood
uh
see you got wood i don't know what i
want right now you [ __ ] can you
give me a moment i know brett
everybody needs to bring brenda don't
try it
all right are you done am i i don't i
doubt i don't know where i want to just
watch this before i make any mistakes
you want to use your cards that's an
eight that's eight fellas if you don't
use your cards you're losing
so [ __ ]
when do you lose the cards how many
moves when you have when someone rolls a
seven and you have too many cards you
lose half of those okay three how many
is too many again okay eight oh okay so
i got time wait so it's every seven hey
if you have more than anybody out there
got brick make me an offer yeah anyone
have brick
you only get my rock nobody no brick
yeah i get my brick you don't have break
oh really you don't
i have three this time we'll talk
shane i'd give you a sheep and a rock
for a brick for one brick
sounds good but i don't really care much
because you don't have any bricks okay
never mind i'll dominate you're not
supposed to see each other's cars
yeah okay yeah but i can tell he's lying
yeah
you'll see
one of these days where you're gonna
have more wood than you can handle
and that's when i come in
i don't have mud
nice all right well
now what
now it's homies turn all right he's just
looking at the board trying to say i've
ended my turn
two
two i did not hear it does anybody have
a two or on a two is it only two
okay so there's one over there
oh
[Music]
oh
i give you two stone for a wood
i'll do that i'll do that i'll do i'll
i'll trade a stone for a shoot you
should say
one yeah two stone for one wood i got no
forests on the board okay
there you go
dude uh
what do you guys think about the police
should we defund them or should no i
think we should punt them ten times and
much make them super police and it'll
just change society in a way that you
know we can't tell but it'll be
different
i'm talking laser gun i'm talking about
every street corner policeman so
something's bound to happen i say
martial law so that would be good i say
we decided who's cool why are you not
drawing that because i [ __ ] bought it
so how many cards do you have if you
have eight or
above then you're [ __ ] did anybody
roll a seven on it yeah yeah yeah i was
just rolling
i just rolled a seven
is that also when the uh robber moves
right yeah yeah then you get to put it
where does he move yeah
oh
okay and then those resources are just
dead there goes yeah
do you want a stone for brick anyone i
think we don't have a lot of break
you're not allowed to do that no you
can't touch it you can't try it on when
it's not your turn oh okay okay all
right am i good
oh my god
oh under the table anyone got rock
yeah
yes you have two rocks you're about to
get rocked
by this left hand do you want uh a hay
for two rocks
do you guys want hay
i'll give you a rock and a sheep for a
hay
i need two rocks
ah
sure
can't do it
i'll give you a break i'll do i'll do
the two rocks for a hay
riley has placed
a road
no
i built a city
already
what do cities look like wow
whoa they're big
is awesome when you get two resources
when it rolls on that city wow
all right your turn okay
it's a bit concerned
oh we got three
hey hey
did you guys go to the anime convention
anyone want to trade uh two sheep for
some red rock
two sheep red rock two sheep do you mean
bread can i give you one talking about
that martian rock i'll give you one
sheep for a red rock yeah he doesn't
have any brick oh determined last time
no my brick was stolen actually is what
just happened
i got pilfered
uh all right i conceived my turn then
ha ha
dude what does that thing in your
microwave say
kill yourself
memento mori
what's that memento means remember and
mori is death
what the [ __ ] it's so dark to have on
your microwave
i know that's
that's more of an oven thing oh no
you're just like eating a hot pocket
you're like damn i'm [ __ ] remember to
take the number or help her out though
okay who wants hey guys i i have to eat
i do yeah brick
ooh
how did you feel about two sheep
i'll give you i'll do it
okay you want to do it again that's all
i can do
you want weight uh can i do that for
brick no i'll give you a wee for bro
dude i just i just got brick i like bro
you got a barter i traded you're saying
you're saying wheat for brick
you can't trade with him
oh it's not his turn okay wait a minute
you want sheep wait a minute you want
sheep
no i got i got sheeps at the wazoo you
want
wheat
i do want to eat yeah brick
yeah but i think i'm saving it for reg
because you're gonna get too powerful
too quick
well
i'm nowhere right now
okay
hmm
you want it
for what
for brick
nah i'm not gonna do it what about two
wheat for two sheep okay deal
hold on
what about tui for three sheep no you
said two man i can't do two or else i
can't build anything that i want
okay what else are you gonna put to
sweeten the deal when i put three sheep
one one other thing to speed in the deal
no i can't
yeah you can do something no these
that's the only cards i have
i need to build a yeah well you're
probably gonna get another wheat in the
next turn because you've got lots of
wheat fields well do you want wheat yeah
too cheap
i need three
two sheep
or you're gonna have to wait a whole
another turn to do anything
oh yeah
i need three sheep
anyone want to eat for what for three
sheep
i'm the only one that's got sheep one
yeah i don't have any use for two sheep
i might as well
keep the wheat then all of these guys
need to work out at rogan's gym okay i
can see here thank you
one two three four one two three one one
settlement road i'm gonna start playing
damn i need to expand here dude there's
this one in my science class in eighth
grade
you move the robber
and you steal and then you everyone has
to count their cards
oh thank god i gave you three sheets so
how did i get this i know
why she dropped me to seven cards
perfect because you roll the seven oh so
seven is the steel night it's the death
number so now where to
place it on like a resource to block it
so like it depends like you want to play
something like a good resource that
blocks like probably the most amount of
people or like whoever you're trying to
[ __ ] over
whoever's winning because you'll you'll
be stopping the resource that he's
winning right now i don't know
about it
about right yeah they're the most number
of dogs but hans is the most valuable oh
wait brian also has a city yeah you just
put it down you put it down over there i
[Music]
yeah
you can move it
yeah
in general it's better to hurt multiple
people yeah this looks like it's [ __ ]
up everyone yeah it was justified it was
already there
that's a low number so just one roll you
just want to get the least amount of
resources into your enemy's hands
possible it doesn't matter that you
spread it out i'm gonna do that
now you can rob uh white or blue okay
uh
let's do whenever you search please
let's do
why yes
oh how did i know
did you guys like don't look up yeah
right
what did you think of it i liked it i
had to fast forward through it because
it was kind of boring but i like the
message and i like the idea behind it
what why do you like what do you like
about the message right because it's
like idiots will just
take a random one
control from the idiots
well in the end we let the idiots win i
know
so we can't let that it's not very like
encouraging it's just oh it's still my
turn right so i could trade with people
yeah yeah do you want i mean what do you
want for a break i have to fast forward
i change i change
yeah well it was just like so cheesy it
felt like it was like
yeah
no but it was a he had a one in seven
chance but does
you can just like make a movie that
makes a lot of times
you can just make a movie that makes
people write feel good i'm just kind of
experimenting right now yeah if you've
got nothing else to do i would just buy
a development card if you've got nothing
else yeah so that's why it's just like i
have thanks
but those people can't be reasoned with
like they were refused
so what's the point of having a
conversation we might as well just
pat ourselves on the back and master
okay four
uh whoever's yeah maybe we should try it
harder i could talk together
maybe we should try harder to talk too
no you don't
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you're adjacent
yeah
i should try harder we should try harder
i'm gonna
uh maybe we should uh try harder to talk
to trump supporters
right
that'll be a [ __ ] start but is
which is very true
i think that's the best but i think i
appreciate their opinion
more than like it's just lower than the
numbers
i think it's easier if we could all just
understand one another but
we have a very
different political system but also
trump was like the epistasis it was like
that was the end of the [ __ ]
republican party your turn
thank you
i'm a trump supporter lol the panthers
poor
i mean
i think trump's better than hillary
why
because it sounds right
that's not how you choose a president
but it was more fun
she's just like
yeah well she's just like not cool
victory points you reach 10 you win
it's like so
boring so i go to hearing joe biden talk
i'm like oh my god like i don't even
care
you're not supposed to be entertained by
the president that's right yeah
you don't need to listen i don't even
want to listen to him you don't have to
live your life cards that just say this
is a victory point so that's another
reason to buy it you can do whatever it
is the road get you if there's no
victory points
it lets you build a settlement because
without a road you can't build a
settlement right you have to be more
than one segment away to build a
settlement
from your current settlement
and there's also a longest road bonus
right yep
it's one victory point and how long does
it have to be to get the bonus i think
it's over six
what bonus
longest road five
five okay
all right are you done
now i'm gonna get a
wood
and a
did you roll a nine i'm getting
okay
if it's past the roll like you probably
shouldn't pick it up well
if it's still up
yeah but it's been a while like he could
have easily passed this trend
yeah i'm playing this yeah
yeah i know but it's been such a long
time it's really not been that long wait
a nine yeah
when did you roll nine
he did it secretly
you just roll or do you roll like a
really so you have to be two away from a
currency
from your current settlement so you
can't i think you can't get that second
or two
yeah you can't build a settlement
anywhere you could build here but he's
already closed i'm trying to get that
yeah you could build here you can build
here but you'd have to build extra roads
to get that
okay all right i'm just gonna get two
more
these guys so i think that the cops
should definitely be defunded
and also we should find social programs
because that's how you stop crying like
a military
no like in the streets like uh social
safety net
like uh healthcare
i just think uh all cops should be black
yeah perfect system that solves the
problem
you know switch it switch it to latinos
being shot in the streets
that's what the irish did the irish were
like let's take over the cop yeah just
start killing the irish i have an idea
what's your idea
what's your idea
i'm irish
exactly i have my dad we got some nick
over here
shane is irish too if you couldn't
luck of tell ira nine it's a nine folks
draw your names
uh but yeah
uh i think we should
give the cops like funny hats so
that way like they're embarrassed to be
cops this is why nothing ever gets
solved i think that would solve a lot
you guys would rather have fun than
funny hats would be i mean it was pretty
good all right so everyone all right
all right did you hear brian simpson
shook
um yes
hey you got wood
cobbler
no he's like
cops are like come back i'm building the
road
but yeah i like stuff because they were
scared for their life it's like that's
fine it's like
you're allowed to be scared like i feel
like before you're a cop we should find
out what you're scared of
it's like instead of like a test being a
like test of the academy it's like just
a haunted house full of black people
playing everyday activities
yeah you gotta make it from the front
yard to cook out in the back
you get your badge at the grill
that guy's so funny yeah yeah
all right that's it for me
nine
nine
oh i mean i think that we are a
generation of selfish people who don't
want to sacrifice anything for anyone
else
oh wait was han's done and then that's
how our cops are too
all right four four four so oh
i mean you used brick still yeah i'm
about to take some i just think cops
should be allowed to do whatever they
want so i got pregnant
to who they i also you know what i'm
saying i think we need to do it yeah
control system well this is my turn so
what should i do
so you can't build a settlement because
it's too close to your current
settlements you could build a road to
connect them if you're trying to do like
uh yeah a continuous road thing yeah i
am all right so let's just build a road
you are a continuous road
i mean now
all right there we go
do you have weed or sheep
uh yeah
you want something
uh i got the stone man yeah can i get
stuff
i'll give you a stone for a sheep all
right deal
all right uh this is still my turn so
i'm going to
uh
oh my gosh there's a lot of times a city
needs to roll seven i need one wipeout
ray anyone have any arts you know what
maybe i should uh you're right maybe i
should uh kind of try and get rid of
this [ __ ] huh you got wood i'll trade
for wood
yeah i do have wood can i get a uh
wait can i get this
wait stop no i'll give
i'll give you a stone and a brick can
you kill yourself please no
i'm gonna get a developer
i'm gonna get a development card so i
can not worry about this [ __ ] anymore is
this [ __ ] or what
i mean you still have more than seven
cards yeah okay i'm awesome here it does
you build the road too
it does something
development card
do you have any wheat and then to go on
the card i'll charge you a
yeah uh gareth don't you have weed i
have cbd
i'm also gonna get a road gareth it's
okay to say you smoke weed it's 20-22
yes
that's a good deal so yeah deal for what
yeah for one would yeah i'm gonna act
high though
but i'm just pretending
all right i'm done i need this
okay
that's cool
cool
okay new settlement on the board
wow
that's how you build this
you put a rock down
you need a wood
oh
and there it is
is your color blue you can't build a
settlement you need to build the road
first oh [ __ ] i didn't know somebody
built there that's where i was going
damn it
okay well i'm taking my ship back
i don't think this dab pen works
i don't even know what it is dude you
want to see uh
my impression of a gen z
do you guys know that there's dab pins
that can write
like those multi pens you can push down
on the red and the blue on the green
and the weed i asked i asked someone to
borrow their pen and they gave me like
an actual pen
so ray you recently posted a video onto
the kill tony subreddit and it got
pretty
high marks almost 200 300 up votes yeah
i think it's one of the most highly
upvoted things this year it is so what
do you think about
your reception to the kill tony
fan base and do you think it's just
because they're desperate for any sort
of attention from
the people that have been on the show
it might be because of that it might be
because i'm sounds like that question is
a little framed might be
might be because i'm uh you know uh
look like an incel and they want
to relate to someone uh that's like them
well luckily you're not an in-cell yeah
intel's a really strong choice for words
i think
i'm the king so are you self
no dude i'll go super saiyan tube right
now [ __ ] wipe your ass out
i'm celery
i'm so salivated come here
so are you saying that hans are you
saying that this is because they just
want to say hi to me that's why i'm
playing and i think it's a part of the
night
yeah it's definitely this is probably
part of that though
this is still information
that you're very funny and that
they appreciate the talent and the skill
okay
i hope so excuse me
we got an eight
oh you [ __ ]
wait i haven't been paying attention
for a while
yeah what what
uh does anybody i need a wheat i think
what do you like to trade
i need a wheat would anyone like to
trade
does anybody have a wheat they want
no
no
no
what about
i'm gonna give you a second
about this you guys two for trade
okay
i need
um
however um
you can
it can tan i will give
someone two sheep for one week
does anybody want two for one
two sheep for one week
dude i think it's uh
[ __ ] up how you put the uh scoreboard
on my face
[Laughter]
no you didn't notice until now
does anybody want to trade a stone i
need a wheat does anybody want to give
me a wheat
for a lot of cards
if you had two wood i'd give it to you i
don't have that you've already said this
all right riley go what's your turn
dude you're not allowed to do that
that's really creepy dude
seven yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh get rid of your [ __ ] no
dude you son of a [ __ ] you had a week
right dude
i held myself
and jiren has let himself go
who is that
probably gareth
because gareth really looks like you
look like a karen in this
look
you look like i feel like shane's your
haircut
oh i got a song it's beanie's up yeah
that's what's going on with me too
no it is this one dude you do kind of
look like a cheering
it
this is like a british game show it's
like one of you is ed sheeran
you must find out which one
no that is the worst game show
you have 30 seconds to find out who is
ed sheeran
what if you were what if who's brown
what if we were
i'm i'm destitute really the scams
you're not allowed to do that dude do
what
yeah i got a sheep what you offering
i'll give you a hay or what oh yeah i'll
take a wood for a sheep i'll take you
two sheep for a wood this guy's the most
[Music]
dude i didn't know bro i said the words
came out of my life he said it like
three times i said it three times i said
i will give you two sheep for one egg
they're really annoying uh ed sheeran
well you know what dude i'm not sure
that ed sheeran sucked my dick that's my
turn very good
okay yeah
that's
seven
oh
nice
whiskey exp gave us five us dollars and
said just showing you guys some love
how's your jiu-jitsu joke got us
laughing yeah by the way how does that
beer taste
anyone what tastes like the great state
of texas
yeah you wish you could
suck oh no it's actually donate five
dollars if you love texas
all right does anyone uh i don't wanna
do uh two sheep for one wheat
two sheep
two whole sheep
whoa
how about three whole sheep
no but riley will then later trade you
one sheep for your first two weeks
yeah oh my god you guys let it go
already jesus it's 20 22.
i've moved on for my past self i i don't
know about you guys
well
i can exchange four cards for one of the
resource right yeah okay you guys trade
in four cards for any one resource by
the way
i'll do this um
the four have to be the same or for any
it's four of the same have any of these
other guys been on kill tony i don't
believe riley has gareth has
riley gareth hahn's actually ray that's
not cassidy these guys aren't comics
shane and
mark aren't comics but i know we're
professional catan players yeah they're
katan nationals they dedicated their
life to katana
well we're out there joking around yeah
they're playing i pretend to forget the
rules are you done yeah you're good
that's how
that's how good you are
you're
yeah
playing mind games
what time is it
what's the question
10.
oh thank
oh thank god
why why always the [ __ ] tone with me
because it's funny why you shut your
[ __ ] goddamn mouth i don't i don't
sound like that
you treat me like riley treats you
these open bikers have donated their
time to these professional catan players
it's a catan open mic right now
katana mike
anyone have a lighter
oh no we just had these matches right
now i mean
eight eight you're saying i'm good we
got eight
yes so what does that mean
so what do you think about joe rogan's
new club i'm so stoked for it when is
that going to happen spanish
and also maybe not that soon but also
maybe in the future sometime but
he's gonna have oh my god that'd be so
sick dude
that's what a club
food is gonna be all like elk
and
i was really excited for the club
sandwich you're gonna order a shot of
vitamin d in the bar get an iv drip in
between soaps yeah is there denny's
around here
are you done
it's a race turn uh yeah i'm done i
don't know what to do i mean
i might have an invitation to go see it
soon so oh that's awesome oh cool seven
i had eight cards how do we how do i
lose them you just pick and choose i
choose how what cars i lose yeah oh okay
well
oh
you choose you lose
i always say i lost my stones
but then i get to move the robber yep
shane i'm taking from you oh no okay
i have really nothing to offer if you
had eight cards you better burn them
one thing i'm sorry it's all good i got
it oh thanks
one two three four riley when did you
get four points
um hey riley [ __ ] you
what how do you even have four points
finally get another settlement
one two one two now i'm at three
we're definitely gonna be a two for the
rest of the game
yeah yeah you're in a pretty
tough spot
he gets the longest road going to that
sheep board over there and all in my
turn what are you with toy story struck
with autism
i bet you like your [ __ ] too okay
i bet you look like absolute hell yeah
i still have seven
let me move this to this
nine right is you guys
oh perfect yeah my favorite comedian is
william montgomery he is [ __ ] really
good yeah
what is your role
uh amy schumer is actually
she's funny but i watch her spot i watch
a little more special do you think she's
funny my my second favorite is uh
brandon shaw problems
well it's because it's old i love
friends we can't we can't talk bad about
reddit shop okay his netflix special was
really special i enjoyed it
special is in uh what you mean by dad
this is like a special olympics version
yeah we should just get rich and paid to
be comedians
did he was do you think it was more
payment or just his connections
brendan chop i think it's just all his
talent as a comedian that's my person i
think he hit the open mics like a like a
champ yeah
he had a real natural talent for it
if you get hit in head enough you become
funny just not in the way you might
expect
i have my turn
you don't think he's funny riley's your
true i mean i think he's funny
i think he's like a little jockey and
bro what did you roll
about seven yeah he's fine i mean we're
gonna figure it out
he's just like growing right in front of
our eyes and he got a showtime special
when he's been doing comedy three years
yeah that's insane that's like it's like
me doing a showdown special right now
or possible how long have you been doing
comedy throughout years
three years
well there are some context claims
well no because i remember you i thought
you told me once eight months
wow okay never mind sure
i feel better now
because i was like i'm not even [ __ ]
close so because you're at the one
ladder competition you and i was like
he's been doing it eight months no no
not at all because at one time we were
christy nova's you yeah i thought and i
mean maybe it was because it was the
coach
in austin for eight months
maybe or maybe it was like a oh before
covet i was doing it eight months
something like that
i think i said i've been in oscar eight
months damn right you've been doing it
like six months six months
so how does it feel to get on kill tony
six months in and then [ __ ]
especially because kill tony was like
what got me to stand up i literally
didn't like stand up before it killed
tommy so this is all like how did you
find kill tony
from uh the h3 podcast they went on you
yeah that's why i guess they were guests
and then i just started watching from
there oh they were guests
yeah that's literally how i got it they
did a good job that's how i i don't
think so because they never came back
but i thought they did fine the only way
to find them yeah i think they did fine
but yeah maybe they're busy but they're
a huge thing i loved ethan because he
was like so snarky like people like this
guy's an idiot let's watch him be an
idiot
yeah i mean i love used to love the show
i used to love ace richter and then he
transitioned into podcasting yeah now
he's just kind of he's banned from
youtube
are you done right yeah for a little bit
what
yeah you don't keep up no i'm i'm kind
of out of it with them now you're born
to kill tony now i'm now entirely into
comedy yeah it's kind of wild transition
well you're always on your laptop when
you're at open mics so it's kind of
weird yeah but that's gonna stop now
well it's it's gonna be me on writing
now not producing or doing anything else
well did you edit that video you put on
like i just wrote it yeah i did so
that's why your skills come into handy
team
yeah h3h3 became shitty
i mean it's so watered down now it's not
even like content anymore yeah it's just
garbage and he started clickbaiting and
becoming really really you know it's
just um
but uh i like his podcast with uh
hassan [ __ ]
okay
yeah that'd be pretty cool
five
[ __ ]
anyone want sheep
no one have wheat wheat for sheep
not for justice oh i get a stone what
about a break sheep would i would do or
a sheep sheep
for a wheat sheep brick i would do
both sheep brick i'm good thank you okay
okay
you're like a merchant at the arabian
market
come back it's a seven so that means i
get to control this right yeah yeah
i'm gonna put it right [ __ ] here yeah
do it wow wow that's the epicenter of
their well [ __ ] pete [ __ ]
and why
he's calling you
[ __ ] slow bag
steals development card yeah
at the end of your turn you can play it
if you want
even on this turn where you already
moved the robbery you can play it again
wow so you want to move it somewhere
else and steal from someone else who has
a bunch of steal one research from the
nervous system i only have one poor
thing
for me adjacent to the robbers next you
know i'm not gonna use this because i'm
gonna
oh
paul walker's corpse is too high in the
ground
is that you right
i better not be goddamned
i i wanna definitely paul walker's not
riley again no it's it's i'm barely in
the corner
i don't know oh yeah he's still he's
gonna go in the corner i'm okay paul
walker's court dude
dude
paul walker wishes
i think he wishes he was a lot could i
build a road or something i think he
wishes
and you're about to get the five long
road which means you're about to go up
the victory point right or does it start
on the six two
yeah you got it bro
so wow
continuous right yeah so there i get a
point yeah yeah put it right there good
for you ray
there you go
i've only got refined opium
oh wow
that sounds delicious
see if we can make a deal
alert
are you done right yeah i'm done
all right that's 10.
so do you think america is a third world
country and how it treats its poor
citizens
yes definitely
because if you look at from the european
perspective america is just what
it's like it's like wild west it's like
oh they basically don't have a
government like how could you treat
people that shitty yeah that's why
goodnight i treat him that shitty every
time they come up to me in the parking
lot outside the creek again
no they're back
back
back
i don't have any change here here go
do you have a
vendor i have a
but i don't want to hurt you no it's
funny you're my neighbor that's fine
that's fine
yeah
it was about what i wanted to seal
oh
homeless problem is easy to solve kevin
bergman says
kevin
i want to hear the solution kevin
kevin
kevin is actually a high-ranking
politician
probably he's the master of homelessness
by the way oh okay he's like the dog
whisperer but for homeless people
they got some cool tests they call that
a home
eleven
on to get two wood
thank you gareth no problem it's eleven
eleven
seven eleven
um you know what i'm gonna do
play my night cars
used to let anyone else build the
longest road card i will build this
[ __ ] road keep building it remove
this
it says it can be taken this card i will
fight to the [ __ ]
that's such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] wait sausage can be taken
it could be yeah somebody else has a
longer road they get it oh yeah
riley alfredo's the longest road
yeah he's got a five-length road
spread
ray longest show the cards
yeah
why am i getting it you're not getting
robbed you're red oh you're right why am
i
[Laughter]
i still wanted that card
to be sustainable well homeless need to
generate some kind of value work in some
way
so here's the thing kevin if you saw the
hate the homeless outside
every monday you would know why they
can't work
oh wait they're just too quick
it's just the homeless aren't working
they can't come
they kick themselves out i hire you to
be a door guy at the vulcan your first
job is to move 500 feet
[Laughter]
we're all hired
i mean from the looks of it they're
already working in the [ __ ] yeah
it's
for what what are you offering
i have a bunch of [ __ ] man do you want
two two wood and a brick
what can you offer in the wood bricky's
going to give you a wood for a hay no
i'll
think now do you think homeless should
be allowed to buy sandwich materials
and give sandwiches to their homeless
friends at the park oh my god what kind
of questions
as long as they finish construction
that's my final offer
i don't know kevin bergman is currently
eating doritos
in a reclined position
[Laughter]
like i'm gonna [ __ ] if you do me a
sheep of wood and one other thing i'll
do it i can't do that man
heroin and sharon jodie foster
i think that's my final offer yeah jody
foster is definitely directed towards
okay i'll take it
oh brenda am i on brenda i don't know
what take your beds kevin
why should i kill it's okay it's fine
it's fine it's fine okay we all get like
kevin's coming up with solutions we all
get that we all get like this what if we
gave all the homeless people oogie's two
weeks
for one seat do we from wednesday
now he's spamming the chat i love you
kevin
he's just a twitch guy
oh my god riley is on youtube
he says he's an engineer anyone wants
sheep
kevin
yeah do you just have two points now you
have three yo does anyone have a break
i'm gonna change that anyone got a brick
i haven't should shirt two on the
scorecard i have a sheet i don't care
hey hans i have three points but i don't
care
really yes look at this
color are you white dude i'll give you
two sheeps for a brick
i'm gonna have to pack these three shoes
this game is happening i'm gonna have to
pass that
all right
[ __ ]
oh riley's coming for your longest road
oh
six you say all right
yeah i got some wheat don't trade with
riley
it might be too early for that yeah i
know something you want some uh you want
some martian rock for some wheat
i don't know what you're talking about
it's clearly a breakfast
it's a square don't trust him don't do
it man you're doing oh you're already
trained all right that concludes my uh
my turn
good riddance bye bye
eight eight
oh
look at that
i do a little road settle
anyone want sheep
and i cut off riley
good
who would you guys rather be your dad uh
bill cosby or jeffrey epstein
jeffrey epstein yeah
also he will set you up with your middle
school girlfriend but i feel like bill
cosby is like a really good speaker like
he would calm you down now listen here
i know you got your first boner in class
tonight
that's 10.
[Laughter]
i was watching
so as long as you didn't just buy it
then yeah during your turn you can say i
use the knight and you move the robber
you usually make a steal i i rolled a
10. okay
i heard jeffrey
who has the most kind of cool guy i'm
going to steal from yeah
where do i go for kids unless you were a
girl in which case he would rape you
sorry wait you roll attention yeah that
would really [ __ ] really yeah yeah if
you want to also [ __ ] yourself that
[ __ ] you
that [ __ ] you over yeah you don't want
to [ __ ] yourself i would literally have
like like
me there or you could do just me there
but that's not a very high value there
i'll do there and then i'm destroying it
so what does that mean that means you
can't farm so that means i get no bricks
and shane gets no bricks maybe that's
our brick you should rock mark
as you can tell my settlement is just
disgusting okay let's i i just did you
oh you're in romney
let me rob you yes
perfecto that's what was that what you
needed
no i know the soccer continues
everything is what i needed all right
that's i'm over so now what the knights
so i just put it back now you just keep
it like kind of sitting that you did it
congrats i think is it
there's a there's an award for like
using a lot of knights right okay orange
isn't there one that's like i broke the
bandits out it's like you lose four
nights or something
yeah
oh and it's a seven
oh [ __ ] dude i screwed myself because i
think i have eight exactly yeah i made
exactly two
one all right give them up man eight you
mean seven exactly eight is where you
lose them
eight or more yeah i gotta lose i have
ten using the context clues i'm trying
to find out who paul walker's corpse is
now
paul walker's corpse needs a bump he's
falling out definitely riley
hey guys wouldn't have been dead in
a long time so
you guys are [ __ ]
do you guys are do you guys can't okay i
ended my turn
what's that how do you guys think yeah
i was gonna do something but then i lost
all my [ __ ] with the seven
peacefully in my sleep eleven that's
just not true
eleven hunts
i think you'll park your van on a near
steep cliff
one day
a near
and steep cliff and it'll just roll off
wait when we get rolled
at 11 11.
there was also seven rolled on my turn
so if you have eight cards or more
better purge
because they have been purged
i think that we should value homeless
people because they're humans and we
should just give them food and shelter
and then hopefully
they'll produce some value for us but to
make them like scrounge for recyclables
yeah and make sandwiches
yeah
it should be quesadillas for them
i think that's weird mr pibb extra says
chinese people descended from ants
thanks for giving voice dude i remember
this guy
he wants to clarify he says i think we
should value asian people
but they're ants
how can you value it honestly like
that'd be pretty crazy if a human came
from an ant like a human turning into a
man
i know it'd blow out the queen's vagina
boom i'm gonna i'm gonna go use beverage
is that why you guys like leave so much
wait i thought did does somebody [ __ ]
the queen aunt is there an is that yeah
she creates males just to [ __ ] her
that's crazy yeah
she [ __ ] herself
yeah so she's more japanese than chinese
what's your song yeah
is it your turn uh ray's going to the
bathroom so
wait wait who's turning yeah i just i
just roast your turn okay so it's
playing with that wait what'd you roll
i rolled a nine okay
oh riley's coming into the lead again
ray
no he didn't i know he didn't i'm just
trying to give him brave man
he's getting there though he can take
that
i'm at four also
oh my god i don't know six points
you knew it as soon as you said it
no
i not as soon as i waited a second
i don't know oh yeah i did
yeah that wasn't right
away
all right somebody's giving you tan
somebody's giving you a weird uh setup
hey hans how many throats does it take
to the bottom of a sucker
what does that even mean no suckers
i'll be there in a
few throats
i feel a little thready
i've
i felt a little hoarse this morning i'm
a horse pedophile that's just what i do
you don't measure your horse and hands
you measure it in throats
no i meant hurting
yeah that's how i also measure
the woman that i write
people used to judge how strong
people were by seeing if they could cut
a horse's head off whoa
like the mountains brother the
mountain's brother or the mountain yeah
based off of real old-time medieval [ __ ]
i don't know it always sounds like a
disaster when you pass that thing but
then nothing happens
it's like whatever
one step away from disaster
a bunch of
what was that roll that was just
just waiting for him to come back unless
world peace is at the bottom of an asian
girl's throat
mr pibb says what do you mean that's
your panda extra give me the top of her
chest
where does how long is this is that our
vagina mr pibb wild mouth right now
so extreme timeout
i hate the idea that we have to have
like every single group of every thought
represented
do you guys think um that i'm gonna die
of a rare disease
probably you probably stage four
lymphoma you're not even aware of it
it's probably you're gonna get a diet
you're protecting
up a lot of illnesses
yeah
what
dude
dude my doctor was like flirting with me
i'm pretty sure that's hot
she's like
check your balls again
i've never had a patient i could see
through you have really big balls can i
see that she was like she was like i'm
gonna need to examine your leader
she was like trying to get me to like
pee in a cup she's like do you want to
pee in a cup for me
usually that's like her thing
all right we got five there's no reason
there's a [ __ ] in a bucket for me
it did hit it
oh
do you want to pee in a cup and then on
my face all right i'm in my turn and i'm
also going to go to the bathroom but
y'all can feel free to roll it
you remember a lot of like sexual stuff
that happened to you
what
like your doctor
well yeah that happened the other day
in north carolina yeah
why don't you just do it dude
why don't you just pee in a cup and be
like
i know you have to pee
i had uh i had are you sure she wasn't
just being a doctor being like you came
in with a urinary tract infection i
don't know she was like uh she was like
do you want to even like look at
anything like physical
dude you should have [ __ ] your doctor
was she like 6 68 years old no crucial
detailer
i probably am just like
thinking of it wrong most definitely
yeah that's a [ __ ] doctor
i don't know
you should have just shown her like a
little bit of ass and if she she felt
into it then you should have gone with
the [ __ ]
yeah you gotta give it you gotta get
slow does this look abnormal to you
shake my ass
it just starts working on it
are y'all familiar with testicular
torsion oh no i'm not terrifying i've
been tested for it every time i coughed
wow every time you coughed yeah every
time i coughed my life was at the
doctors you would know it if you had
what yeah they say uh you know turn your
head aside and cough that's a circular
torsion test
so i just i never chose to cough before
then
why do they give you so much tests
oh no i do it every year you never got
that no because they're twisting his
balls
my balls are pristine they're twisting
his hands twisting my balls over here
i'm walking hey you're twisting my butt
no trust me you know you have it when
you when you have oh it sounds
terrifying it sounds so bad my friend
lost the ball because it twisted and
then he lost blood supply and they lost
the testicle oh my god do you have
clothes still
yeah yeah what did it hurt a lot yeah i
wonder if it was very painful oh but i
went to the doctor and then uh this
really hot nurse
was like all right we need to do a uh
you know what is it whatever sonogram
like whatever they're doing for the
pregnant woman yeah yeah but then she's
like i need to lather this ky all over
me oh
why you're a dick
oh a little bit of shaft it was just the
tiny
part she she cut she like she's like you
need to move the
you got to move that up it's like it's
moving it's moving itself
and i was like [ __ ] you don't need to
worry about that don't worry it's moving
it's going to be a lot of movement
yeah and then uh everything was good
down there they like twisted she gave it
a little twist
she gave her a little twist like a
mustache yeah
should i grab it and give it a little
little twist like that
what are you [ __ ] talking about
testicular abortion untwist your balls
she just kind of gave it yeah they were
not she
that's all she did it's just like she's
giving me talk
oh i don't want you what kept you from
being able to do that you know i don't
know
i
i'm not a doctor what if we were just
like unscrewing a bottle cap i mean i
had a hard time like i think my testicle
already happened
sorry so i just received something like
work for them you know okay all right
that's all it was it was just like a
tune-up
dude one time one time dude sometimes my
ball goes above my dick does that ever
happen to you yeah
no no no
yeah that's the division
it goes like eight like i feel like it's
sucked up
i hear a noise
that's what happens it's like can i
examine this physically
it's like it's like you ever go to like
the bank and then you have to put that
thing in it
what'd you roll
i rolled with six wait hans what did you
roll doesn't i don't remember
did ray roll
roll yeah he rolled six year old what
are you training for ray
at this point i'm just thinking about
testicular torsion
yeah it wasn't so you don't want any
sheep use today
uh
dude
also like
i feel like one of my balls is like
detached i'll give you a sheep and a
rock for i want hey
that's what i want i want what sounds
like something your doctor could have
examined
yeah
why didn't you get your balls examined
man
[Laughter]
yeah no i can't do anything
and it's like fully naked just like okay
you want to walk
yeah
they're just like all right
oh thank god okay 10. i'm like little
chilly in here
oh my god
that would give her that would give that
dog church she'd be like whoa hey
sorry
no you're good i have a feeling mr pibb
in the chat is one of the homeless
people on sixth street
dude mr pip i you know what i know that
guy he's a good guy he'll sell you a
crack ray
yeah now
he's a little extra
he's really he's misunderstood
should i put him on timeout yeah put him
on timeout hey mr pip we're going to put
you on timeout
oh you're going to jail just so you know
you know
you know
uh you can also
you know
maybe after time out be a little bit
nicer
i ain't mentioned
fiverrs mr pippa's red band
sorry
i think it meant sorry
all right mr pimp we forgive you
mr president you're a good guy i haven't
been reading the chat but i assume
you're a good guy
he's insulting you he said einstein
always knew best that's right he said
soy put him on time now [ __ ] this guy i
think he meant sorry uh-oh
owen r is so close
i think you should say yeah yeah
oh no yeah you're sorry maybe we need to
teach this guy a lesson he'll never
forget yeah yeah let's do it
we need to make him pee in a cup sorry
just trolling yeah see he's a good guy
he was saying sorry the whole time and
you thought to judge him no he wasn't
dude this guy's an [ __ ] dude this guy
this guy is a known cereal
baby rapist i'm pretty sure
i'm done now
we built some roads who's hyped to be
taking me back to the [ __ ] uh
buzz mill at six in the morning oh hi
i can get arrested
oh and check on the dog i bet the dog is
out there
laying in the water in the pool of blood
right yeah we're taking care of it
police he's like this is a 311 ready
[Music]
oh that [ __ ] dude
he's still right
he's like i've been working 47 straight
hours is like 11 whether you like it or
not i may close out the shift at 95
40 hours
i've been working 200 hours straight i
just sleep anyone got a wood
what are you giving video effort oh my
gosh
lord i'll give you a sheep what that's
[ __ ] no you have to be better off
than man all right
sweatshirt looks like paul from american
food pie
well then um
also wait he has the longest road
yeah
is that nine points yeah
okay
so who the [ __ ] put the robber on some
[ __ ] ass spot in the middle and
isn't [ __ ] over riley it wasn't me
this time no no he somehow flew under
the radar while being leaps and bounds
ahead of everyone else
i was saying it the whole time
is it my turn
yeah you're in the longest round ryan
card
did i have to roll first
wait is that two victory points for
longest road
i would like to steal from you i don't
know how many cars yeah okay yeah
who's right oh riley's about to win
riley's at nine all right raymond i'm
stealing from you yeah oh that's great
thank you raymond
all right now time to roll from right a
guy with two
points know
so those who have nothing all will be
taken it's like beating an elephant oh
it's a baby well we get six yeah we got
six
okay
perfect they should prioritize beating a
presence when they're crazy does
creamy mint creamy man i'm gonna love
this whoever
do i put my knife does she have a little
bit
i hope she doesn't know her things i
don't think it's a she
i uh
i think it's a dude so concludes my turn
hey dude do you even know only fans
10.
oh
look at me wheat pasta
wow congratulations your plan works how
does it feel
how does one feel
anyone want sheep your cutie
says creamy mitt
dude creamy maybe cream is hot you don't
know she's screaming right now that name
let's see
anyone want sheep
ooh for what what do you would what are
you looking for wood
honestly if there were no sheep in the
entire world i still wouldn't want to
shoot no i can't do it i'm sorry
wow dude
all right three three three oh hell yeah
oh nice
to play yeah brother
yeah
three so bad well
a bunch of three is he training for
anything right
yeah can i give you a sheep for a city
for a whole city
you know you do this sheep can you
imagine i have one sheep i would like to
buy your city
wow that's basically what they did to
buy new york the dutch went and if you
if you gave me enough for two roads i'd
give you enough for a full city really
yeah it was literally like for like 23
pet pelts or like it was basically
nothing and then they didn't know the
value of anything back then
these goddamn indians were like sharing
[ __ ] he's like how much for all of
alaska i don't know three dollars
you gave me two roads i'll give you a
city
okay what do you want there's a sheep
no two roads like two bricks and two
woods i don't have two brakes bro i
don't have [ __ ] you know i have [ __ ] no
i've been the slob in this
thing everyone's been [ __ ] me in the
end it's the entire time i'll give you
two sheep for one wood i don't even have
my longest road anymore
you'll never have it again now you're
screwed you got nothing [ __ ]
i don't even have a brick oh so you do
have brick i don't yeah
i'll trade for break though someone
needs to [ __ ] over riley i'll i quit
no i don't quit i i might try who's
closest to building longest road
you i can do it
oh [ __ ]
i need three more roads okay
seven again jesus christ it's always
seven and i have eight
i have seven
all right here we go
creamy mint was totally a dude
yeah i'm pretty sure they're older
you think there's all right if you're
if you're the robber's moving don't say
anything if you're please [ __ ] over
riley
yeah clearly
what's riley's best spot
probably the rock
he gets double but it's so rare
and i'm thinking i get to screw up for
other people with the six
yeah that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
take it from riley
oh wow
original
that we're all gonna take from you dude
okay i end my turn i'm gonna take the
dub how many nights do you have to use
to get like a biggest warrior or
whatever
so
i'm not
you have one two three four five you
have six points yeah
maybe see maybe one how who has a brick
does anybody need hey
oh i need a brick i'll give you two
bricks for too hard
oh that's a good deal
okay
these two
wood
oh [ __ ] riley
oh do you have thongs right now oh [ __ ]
two three four five no i'm not quite now
we are trying to need one more i don't
want to trade what do you need
i don't i can't there's no way i have
one card what is it it's a wheat you
want to trade me a oh a road i only have
wood
i don't know i already have the
materials
a
road
you'll be rewarded by the other players
if you have a wood and a brick you want
to get together spin the game yeah
whatever
riley
oh i think it's riley's time no it's not
it's fine
three uh-huh i'm rich and cheap
all right i'm gonna build a city oh god
damn
the world of the game [ __ ] say
something
no that would increase the drama that
was good
okay let's play for a second no no
you don't get to decide
yeah well that means i have to do
nothing that's what you've been doing
the whole time no i've been winning i've
been secretly winning this whole time
yeah now secretly why don't we just play
another one riley
plays me i'm going to go vape
no
you win second place are we gonna play
another game or are we calling it i
think we should call him yeah
yeah because uh riley you want to play
another game
no
okay
oh wow
[ __ ]
this guy says i like having big what is
it gagging on big black sausages
he's just a fan of germany all right
yeah
i guess
i think he meant saw six all these
people are so obsessed with the fouls i
know well they came to an all-male board
game night online
yeah yeah it takes a certain type of
person no it could look good
girls that we can chat with
you belle delphine on here
that's creamy mint's real identity
and gareth just snubbed her oh no it's a
dude he's saying right now
give me some wood
you should collab with some
hot girls
yeah if creamy mint if you turn out to
be a hot eager uh
call upon first
because you gotta you gotta bang hans
first yeah if you transition
yeah
that's how it goes dude
pepsi always let bun be hit first
that's how was done i really could have
won
try to play odd
if you get a city early it's so much
better than a settlement because you get
a city you double your
thoughts on a spot that has a lot of
dots but just like so your resources go
insane
yeah but if you build a settlement you
get more dots on a place that probably
doesn't have a lot of dots because all
the best spots are already taken riley
built a city on his first turn i think
yeah right like you built one really
early
yeah yeah i know
an expert it's all thanks to ray
he gave me two weeks god damn good job
raymond dude ray you piece of [ __ ]
ray actually had four points at one
point yeah i was doing well all right
secret fourth point
uh oh you had one in your uh that's
right yeah
well too bad
you know what riley [ __ ] you give me
that over there wait what are you doing
tomorrow do you ever work you gotta uber
you're back to uber dude i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna do
you don't want to come work for
sun power solar power they are hiring
right now why are you telling him what
his company is called oh i'm sorry i
meant uh anyway
anything else yeah if derek can do it
you can do it
is it fun though
no it's a job
wait is derek even doing that anymore no
he got fired i get yeah i got the
impression that he got fired i have no
no no idea how i got that impression but
yeah fire
fire
solar is not good dude um
it's funny because if you had a job in
solar
then you could pay your bills and then
work from home and then go to mike's
late at night
i don't want to work from home can i
work in the office
what a cuck
what dude
i don't want to work from home
i can't work
why do you want to go because i get so
lazy
honestly i totally understand it worked
from home before the office just said i
slept all day
sounds awesome
the office has uh like a full-on gym
they have like a legit gym it's like two
stories and then they have why don't you
just get a gym membership and then drive
around in a circle for 30 minutes
every day
okay
anyway it also has a bunch of food
trucks and some other stuff as well it's
a great [ __ ] facility dude
do you have like a nature trail thing
what the [ __ ] is how big is this place
it's huge
but it's also encompassed where are the
people they're are they are they cool or
they're like oh i love my job dude
everybody's really nice
what are they just like corporate no
i don't always just
you just gotta not be not derek devil
not at all i love my co-workers what
happened with their example should i he
took a three-week vacation with a week
notice
it was like hey by the way i'm gonna
leave for three weeks and they fired a
fusion yeah what it is
he works from home why couldn't he just
do it from mexico
because he's an idiot and he didn't want
to do it for mexico and he wanted to
argue with my boss about that actually
technically i should be allowed to do
this yeah no exactly that's what he
sounded like i should be able to just
beat the [ __ ] out of craig for goliath
he put his hands on doug
this podcast yes
yeah this is not
about it's not a portion anyone's here
there's guys
folks
skip this part well just wait until
derrick gets on
that he signs up
oh my god he signs up yeah one day and
tony himself is going to tell him to set
himself on fire
i hope so but maybe he'll have a good
set just actually no he wouldn't and uh
also i think uh he well actually tony i
think kind of knows him because they
paid he told me he tried to go up and
tell a story or make it into a funny
story about how he beat tony hitchcliff
at trivia
you know intellectually well the story
was not funny and he was just sounding
like a dip [ __ ]
i was just like uh derek you're over the
time limit uh getting [ __ ] together and
uh that's not funny you get off the
stage
it's like so it was like uh it was a
couple weeks ago or like a week or so
ago what's your favorite open mic
oh uh derrick dumble terry devil i love
derek though
i like riley's first one
yeah riley's right up there man
absolutely
more like riley feel more i like
uh just feels more than we do
yeah
i felt that wind
beat you guys
i look like you've been there before
i
yeah yeah
i'm really good at this game
there's almost no energy
so
it's your expertise
i don't like uh
riley and then all your roommates as
well
they all got really good vibes doing
great stuff
there's a lot of really funny people in
this city but there is yeah there's a
lot of really good casey rocket casey
rock's fine he's he's got shows though
now
yes i guess he's no longer known for my
girl huh yeah that's a good amount less
than comics asana mod
um david austin comic would be uh
probably william on family
dude this isn't cool i don't know this
guy's creeping me out can you put that
dude on time
mr pig mr pips
mr pip
the guy that's trying to [ __ ] me
[Laughter]
creamy man yeah it's really [ __ ]
weird at this point yeah dude that guy
came working
all right guys how many of you are
jerking off oh yeah raising i i have
been on that table but i haven't shown
it on camp
everyone raise your [ __ ] if you're
jerking off everyone squirt one in there
everyone type headed doctor to twist my
balls oh you look sad can i hug you
don't
don't feed them it's not the same troll
though it's brad
brad hasn't talked for an hour that's
good dude i'm all good man what's that
oh
it's just a little lag chill out buddy
should i put mr pippin timeout no no
this picture dude mr pip yes yes
yeah mr bib sucks dick yeah put him down
you're gonna put chronomet and or
whatever
he's not that bad he's a good guy oops
mr pips probably a [ __ ] uh he was
spammy though yeah he was spamming
should i add him as moderator
absolutely
like immediately there's like some kind
of repercussions for being chinese on
this channel
let's go check out his channel let's see
mr pipp's videos
all right
this is exactly what you wanted isn't it
channel has new videos he's hiding from
us
oh my new account too october 8th
danny's probably russian
you just got to use his parents account
for his first time you think he just
really likes katan he's probably an isis
he's like who are these people playing
guitar right now
isis loves mr pimp
let's talk about um
probably like my dad's co-worker
i should make one of these people a
moderator
yeah
you should
i've been from mr brad
i'm brad
yeah
i'm brad you're a moderator now
let's see how you do it
time out mr pip
engage the chat somehow start
start some sort of trend
let's start some rumors
uh hey do you guys hear that
get everyone
just get everyone excited to be here
he's going to be our hype man
pepper pam
um so i'm gonna go shooting guns with
joe rogan soon
whoa dude that's dangerous man
dad can i come i know what if joe rogan
freaks out
[Music]
what if you accidentally shoot his
dog
you know where to get him a new dog
beautiful
yeah yeah what if he ran away and then
came back and then picked up his dog and
then ran off with them
that dog should have been like oh [ __ ]
we doing this all right i got you i'll
meet you back at the crib
also if you're gonna steal six hundred
dollars don't tie your dog up no exactly
let the dog run with you it could keep
that wasn't it wasn't that day it was
apparently a week ago when you stole the
600 oh that's why the cop was saying he
had a warrant on him yeah
we came to serve that warrant what's
funny is like nothing would have
happened if he didn't just start running
how would they have known who he was
that's what i'm looking for like the cop
was there looking drunk cop is there the
police officer was literally drunk
he actually was drunk yeah that's
hilarious but he had found the guy
clearly because the guy started running
he's using the drunken master style of
policing it's either he's drunk or who's
low on his
he drove up and kind of stumbled around
there was something legitimate
let me operate an automobile well
anyways he probably killed the dog but
it's okay he probably himself
there's a but
to the girl this is collateral oh for
the 600 bucks yeah
that was a great idea and you know the
douchebag here
can't pay your rent
that was a good good because here's the
bigger german shepherd i have like
10 pockets on me right now dude
that's a good good dog
i'll take these
dude crazy things are a foot at buzz
mill buzz mills always it was a weird
night tonight the energy was so wild
before or after the cop tackled the van
the whole night
did you tell me that that guy got
tackled yeah
you're dead your story is totally
different he didn't get tackled yeah he
like got chased out and he was doing
like this
he got like
fun
like the [ __ ] btk killer yeah again
the buzz mill uh like the buzz mill
worker seemed
like he was the real criminal yeah i
thought he was going to shoot it at the
place up
the guy who worked there being in an
open mind just running up to the stage
just imagine being an open mic and
you're performing and you're watching a
police officer approach you with a taser
out yeah it was like during my
performances you know but
i was talking to the cop later he was
like yeah he was wrong i didn't taste
him uh i didn't get to taste them
because you know cop is so drunk and
yeah dude
he's like i should have tasted him
[Laughter]
that's what the cops look for they get
they get off on like what they get to do
to people yeah yeah that's [ __ ] yeah
i think you could name it because the
guy started weaving among people in the
audience yeah and so i think the cop
couldn't
and that's funny if he gets someone else
oh yeah
but yeah i think he just forgot to daze
him because he was just like hammered
yeah he's probably like 35. he's a
pretty hefty dude like he's big dude he
looked like a like a guy that probably
went home and just beat the [ __ ] out of
his kids
no he's a cool guy bro he's a really
cool guy he's like
drunk on his job of carrying a gun
around dude the young the young people
came later
patrick was saying he was like he went
up to me he's like hello officer and
he's like what's up
yeah
brad is like this guy should be
president he's so cool dude i mean he's
a cool guy
that's all it takes
you can be a cop and get drunk but if
you're cool i've gotten into an uber
where you need more cops like that yeah
we don't need heart out cops we need
cops that are cool
yeah
i [ __ ] agree that's very maybe not
getting drunk while
in uniform
yeah no that would be nice but that's
too much of a joke
he gets drunk and playing clothes then
he puts on the uniform honestly he's
probably better at fighting when he's
drunk yeah
he definitely he definitely had that
style he's also probably better at
putting dogs down with this 45 when he's
drunk
he's like yeah i'm okay all right
all right boys
what's going on here
in our hearts though
it's like sand dollars or something